there have been many cultural memes that
have come out of The Simpsons one of
which is Homer Simpsons strangling his
son Bart but apparently no longer W
that's quite a grip see March strangling
the boy has paid off just kidding I
don't do that anymore times have
changed so it's a little joke about this
meme from The Simpsons but it's actually
The Simpsons telling you something real
about the show and about how the
political correctness has affected the
show Homer doesn't strangle Bart anymore
used to be whenever Bart would do
something bad and we would go strangle
him Bart's
like but now they don't do that it's not
that it was culturally accepted to
strangle your children it was a joke it
was a joke about as sometimes your kids
get on your nerves and you just want to
ring their little necks you know but
you're not you don't actually want to do
it you love your kids we're not allowed
to even joke about that anymore however
now we are allowed to uh castrate our
children